hello and welcome to this video playing
it do i cc-can we dim the ICC probably
not especially cough yeah I don't know
how often I played the white side of
this fat shake off not often but you
should try new things once in a while
and for me it's a playing the open
sister in here they often go H form
earlier maybe maybe it's something that
I should have done as well yeah probably
he will take this opportunity and
exchange the dark squared bishop yeah
this is a position where um black should
be okay I think
Brooke t1 and I don't know maybe I could
have done maybe I could have taken the
other one yeah I see deciding which
route to take maybe okay so this
basically means he's not trying to play
can I do this here it could be
interesting let's do this it should
actually asked him an annoying question
because taking he cannot take with the
night at all and do you want to take
with the bishop and give me the open
diagonal him yeah I don't think he
wanted to take but she kind of had to
take so f6 is something that could be
interested in here or just like
strategically addict we should be formed
this is also useful move you should be
for Queenie of three and then double up
on the deep deep on I have f6 as well as
an idea maybe he um has to try 7065
you
i'm unsure him don't think that blacks
position is comfortable to play I have
an idea maybe maybe you should try to
move the king and plain ig8 to f6 not
sure could be idea if I get in Bishop
before Queen er3 the move f5 to f6 it's
something he has to address it cannot
allow this maybe I could have played
Bishop before immediately actually be
three was a purely prophylactic move and
maybe it wasn't necessary let ya went f6
voluntarily okay I'm covering this first
half porn and what next probably okay
yeah taketake first thing later that's
one of those situations and I definitely
don't want the night to come to to
deform I don't know if I want to trade
Queens but if I go somewhere Queen I
would like to play rook t5 and keep
queens on I just wonder about this if he
can get in d5 if i move the Queen back
to III or something is he going d5 take
root take some group to c 1 i'm not sure
about it I mean this is how a better
ending but I did it didn't feel like the
best possible outcome
I'm gonna take a five now after a four
yeah I think I go here right pillar
attacking the beep on so if it takes
texts okay 3i take on before
I can snuggle on a very good ending for
one in still as the d6 porn as a
permanent weakness so in 10 9 c 50 c 5
king yourself I can take root chaos
would be some checker Windsor so um how
to do this probably first of all keep
the pawns and then the group c 5 6 7
maybe I think I want to keep the pawn
there on f5 keep him boxed in time it's
probably trying to recruit this one yeah
come around but I should have this song
look here and Roxy 7 let's do this here
you will take up with seven know who did
I blunder that I did blunder the spawn
Wow making making life difficult again
here oh yeah my attention and it's
really a problem I mean this game was
was yeah
what was it was over basically the heart
of you if you give away if you give away
stuff so
if he takes a five I can always like
Europe before will capture cut him off
let's do this first
time morning they probably have to have
to ditch it otherwise I don't make any
progress in b6 doesn't help don't I
don't also don't get a minute's oops
wrong em yeah I probably cannot cannot
win anyone believable I screwed it up
yet again so anyway to try I can I can I
can do this probably without risking all
that much check check check check check
check check check block hornfels on time
capsule I'm what the heck did I two down
yeah I just blundered t6 I was really
thinking I have this covered I mean I
thought really rooks his seven and TV he
cannot take it really weird how much did
I mean I played this reasonably quickly
but I was thinking before I mean I can
hmm and nothing happens I just I just
make make slow progress him okay so
let's have a look here
it is the c-4 line is currently one of
the fashionable lines here against the
specially cough I mean not not super
fashionable it was it was quite popular
some time ago and yeah I think this has
probably been played maybe not this
precise g3 age for combination but it
looks looks quite normal and here I
think black should be definitely okay
even though the engine gives nine and
five like even here already so probably
probably night f5 is something that you
should address somehow Quincy seven
maybe his Panem like here there is some
something hanging and okay so i could
play Knight a5 one move earlier i only
saw this idea here and okay the engine
what does the engine want to do just go
back yeah I cannot take it probably on I
can't take it oh I got this F 398 yeah
that's okay for blacklisting so this was
a better defense than taking and now
this is the nice position maybe b3 was a
bit sloppy Bishop before immediately is
probably been hard getting this thread
in it was the kind of room the routine
move and yeah I go he can go with your
fire ha ah very cool if I take here
that's probably what C 3 s rooks III and
this start working no one can take here
okay this is a double check important so
then then d5 isn't all that great right
if I can go to the forum
yeah this is the engines idea Tim it
doesn't seem to be all that great now
but it's it's probably a bit better Oh
d5 and now d5 there is this rook c3 for
real because I cannot go to you form ah
ok so i should play this instead yes ok
yeah and here and here going to the
endgame is ok yeah this is good him this
is good the problem is here this book c3
I didn't see this Eddie arrow so he had
a good opportunity chat and this ending
is pretty awful I'm winning a pawn
already somehow a or deep on one of them
will will drop him Ruby 5 i'm ok with my
pleasure like here no blunder the poor
ha ha i don't know if i can still win
this seems seems questionable I should
play age 5 here right here I saw that a
little bit later like after here I
thought that this is an idea but he
stopped it now and this is a good a good
good good move I shouldn't win here
probably yeah I tried I tried this but
it is objectively not i'm not going to
work somehow him like here you can still
play here this was a bit strange that he
allowed this in the first place because
he can just play The King and I was a
bit surprised you should be able to play
just this and maybe he was worried about
this move but
shouldn't be a problem f2f pawns I mean
now let's add raw talent here come now
it's losing going to the engine rook be
one yeah then it comes like this up here
and now click here blocking okay okay i
know i can just enter with the king is
also always this idea with the book
trade idea with rookie and here this or
27 that will also often win yeah okay i
was i was sloppy and in them in the
technical phase of this game and yeah
thanks for watching